bonne rentrée à tous ses fans et aux
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux alors pendant ce petit palais
aux news numéro 18 nous allons discuter
de tout ce qui s'est passé cet été et
que vous avez peut-être raté parce que
vous étiez en vacances mais nous on ne
se repose jamais la science ne se repose
jamais les publications continue à
sortir les nouvelles continuent à sortir
mais du coup ça passe sous le radar
parce que tout le monde est en vacances
donc voilà on va faire un petit une
petite séance de rattrapage de ce que
vous avez peut-être ou peut-être pas
rater cet été et on commence directement
avec ce que je pense être une initiative
très intéressante c'est une initiative
qui a été lancé par le professeur
l'iburger qui est pas paléo
anthropologue à l'université du
witwatersrand
donc c'est un de mes collègues à
johannesbourg et donc il a il a lancé sa
propre chaîne qui s'appelle de faux sol
volts
vous pouvez voir qu'il a très peu
d'abonnés pour le moment donc allez-y
abonnez vous ali burger il a lancé sa
chaîne qui s'appelle le faux sol volts
qui rencontrait un succès extrêmement
moyens enfin je sais pas si vous voyez
ici des vidéos mais voyez que le nombre
de vues dans les premières vidéos
étaient vraiment très faibles jusqu'à ce
qu'il commence en fait à une série de
vidéos où il parle de ses découvertes en
direct c'est à dire que eux ils ont
découvert une nouvelle grotte dans le
cradle of humankind donc le berceau de
l'humanité près de johannesbourg encore
une fois le cradle of humankind c'est
l'appellation de l'unesco ce n'est pas
moi qui appelle ça le berceau de
l'humanité à chaque fois j'ai des
commentaires là dessus il faut pas
appeler ça le berceau de l'humanité si
c'est son nom l'unesco l'appelle comme
ça
donc voilà c'est l'appellation unesco le
berceau de l'humanité donc le jeu n'est
pas décider moi-même d'appeler l'afrique
du sud le berceau de l'humanité
donc bref il a découvert une nouvelle
grotte dans le berceau de l'humanité
près de johannesbourg et dans cette
grotte ils ont découvert un nouvel
hominidé est en fait ont ils fait d'une
série de vidéos et c'est quasiment en
direct vous pouvez voir la 5 jours 4
jours il ya un jour il a dit qu'il en
sortirait une encore ce week-end donc
pour l'instant il ya que trois vidéos
mais d'ici à ce que cette vidéo ce paléo
news sorte il y en aura peut-être une
quatrième est en gros ils ont découvert
un nouveau restent dominés et il parle
de ce nouveau reste de ces nouveaux
fossiles d'homininés donc au début
comment ils les ont découvert là c'est
la préparation comment ils ont commencé
à creuser la roche pour trouver le
fossile et là vous pouvez voir la
première dans d'homininés qui sort donc
c'est vraiment très intéressant comme
démarche parce que là pour le coup c'est
vraiment foule transparence quoi s'est
il ya vraiment il ya vraiment enfin je
crois pas du mois qui est de tricherie
évidemment il ya du montage dans ce
qu'il nous montre les vidéos elles font
que quelques minutes donc il ya
forcément du montage mais au moins on
voit vraiment le comment cette
découverte a été faite au début comment
cette découverte maintenant ce est en
train de se révéler aux yeux bat de
l'iburger mais aussi des préparateurs du
coup on voit aussi le travail des
préparateurs donc ça vous montre aussi
un peu le background tout ça vous montre
ce qu'il ya derrière en fait les
découvertes et c'est surtout ça je pense
qu'il est intéressant c'est que grâce à
ça du moins si 6e fossiles d'hominidés
au moins aussi intéressant qu'il
aimerait qu'il le soit
grâce à ça vous allez voir à peu près
combien de temps il ya entre la
découverte d'un fossile et la
publication de la nouvelle dans la
presse et ça risque de prendre quelques
années au moins quelques mois voire
quelques années d'ailleurs après on
pourrait justement ce je vais pouvoir
enchaîner là dessus parce que vous vous
demandez certainement quel est le niveau
d'honnêteté de la démarche
je sais par des bruits de couloir parce
qu'évidemment je travaille dans la même
institution qu lui donc je sais par des
bruits de couloir que cette grotte il
n'a pas découverte
il n'a pas des coups
ouverte il y a cinq jours en réalité ça
fait deux ans qu'ils connaissent la
grotte mais même dans cette vidéo là il
explique que ça fait même d ça fait
presque 100 ans en fait qu'il connaisse
cette grotte mais je sais que ça fait au
moins deux ans qu'ils savent qu'il y à
deux lots mini nez dans cette grotte
alors qu'il ya 100 ans ils ne savaient
pas ça voilà mais donc cette grotte elle
est connue depuis très longtemps il ya
même un film qui a été tourné d'entrée
morse 5 pour ceux qui connaissent la
série des tremors voilà c'est des gros
nanar d'horreur donc il ya même des
films qui ont été tournés là dedans
donc c'est une grotte qui est très connu
mais on savait pas qu'il y avait de
l'hominidé c'est seulement avec
l'iburger qu'ils ont découverte c'est
seulement le libérateur qui a découverte
qui avait vraiment des hominidés des
homininés dedans et moi ça fait deux ans
que j'en entends parler par des bruits
de couloir qu'il y aurait des fossiles
dans cette grotte donc c'est en direct
mais il a mis longtemps à 6 m voilà
c'est en direct mais je pense que c'est
le coronavirus en fait c'est le le fait
qu'on s'est retrouvé coincé comme lui la
bid
vraiment juste à côté du cradle of
humankind bail s'est mis à bosser full
time sur le sur la recherche de nouveaux
sites et du coup il s'est dit tiens si
je retournais dans cet endroit où on
sait qu'on avait trouvé de l'hominidé il
ya deux ans et je pense que c'est ça qui
s'est produit à mon avis c'est que c'est
vraiment le coronavirus qui lui a fait
dire à léon
on n'a qu'à faire ça voilà donc bref
c'est une démarche qui est assez honnête
je
après connaissant un peu le personnage
de l'iburger je pense qu'il va essayer
de pimp est un peu le truc parce que
c'est
c'est un excellent c'est une personne
qui sait très bien communiquer vous
allez voir qu'il parle à la caméra
beaucoup plus facilement que je ne le
fais d'ailleurs moi je parle pas face
caméra voilà tout simplement à part dans
le coin en bas à droite là mais sinon je
parle pas face caméra mais bref il parle
vous allez voir qu'il s'exprime très
bien à la caméra c'est un excellent il
fait très très bien de la communication
scientifique
c'est très agréable à écouter c'est en
anglais mais on comprend relativement
bien si vous avez des bases d'anglais
vous pouvez très bien comprendre en plus
vous voyez que la cote c'est là là quand
le son est mauvais en plus il a mis des
sous titres donc c'est vraiment sympa et
oui donc il risque de pimp est un petit
peu je pense la découverte d'une parce
qu'il prend un risque
évidemment vous montrant les les
découvertes qu'il fait en direct c'est à
dire qu'il prend le risque que ce qu'il
a découvert ce soit pas important du
tout et que du coup ça fait il fait des
vidéos pour rien je veux dire il ne
saura pas tant qu'il n'aura pas tous
dégagés bon évidemment comme j'ai dit je
pense que je pense qu'il serait pas
aller vers cette initiative s'il n'y
avait rien d'intéressant je pense que ça
fait déjà deux ans qu'il y pense que sa
mâture dans sa tête
donc je pense qu'il ya pas trop de
risques que la découverte soit d'une
importance moindre mais quand même il
prend quand même ce risque
donc à mon avis il n'hésitera pas à peu
à un pimp et une fois de temps en temps
l'importance de la découverte donc
cherché un petit bras c'est un petit
avertissement toile à ce faux pas non
plus être complètement complètement
hypnotisé par la grandeur apparente de
la découverte faux mais c'est
intéressant comme je disais de voir le
de backstage
voilà là par exemple dans cette vidéo là
je crois que le préparateur va lui
suggérer que c'est possiblement
paranthropus robustus parce que là il ya
une dent et qu'elle est très très grosse
et que l'ibère girl va dire non non moi
je veux pas que ce soit paranthropus
robustus parce que si c'est paranthropus
robustus ça n'intéresse personne donc
voilà c'est par exemple ça donc démarche
très intéressante à suivre avec avec
quand même en gardant à l'esprit que
c'est comme
comme ce chercheur prend un risque je
pense qu'il va il va quand même essayer
de rendre ça un peu plus shiny un peu
plus un peu plus glossy que ça ne l'est
en réalité mais en tout cas voilà une
découverte d'un nouvel hominidé de toute
façon c'est jamais pas important quoi
qu'il arrive c'est comme il le dit dans
au début de cette série de vidéos il ya
des gens qui passent enfin iliad et
paléanthropologue qui vont passer toute
leur vie sans jamais découvrir un seul
faux cils d'êtres humains quoi donc là
le fait qu'il nous montre ça en direct
faut quand même savoir que c'est une
démarche qui est très très très
exceptionnelle
c'est une démonstration de transparence
à ces housses venant d'un de la paléo du
milieu de la paléoanthropologie le
milieu de la paléoanthropologie c'est un
milieu qui il ya tellement de
concurrence entre les scientifiques que
généralement les scientifiques refusent
de communiquer sur leurs découvertes
même une fois qu'elles sont publiées il
ya beaucoup de scientifiques qui font ça
même une fois qu'ils sont plus que les
découvertes sont publiés il refuse de
communiquer parce qu'ils ont trop peur
que ça se dissémine que ça leur échappe
parce que c'est un milieu à très forte
concurrence encore une fois donc il ya
beaucoup
il ya beaucoup de chercheurs pour pas
beaucoup de fossiles et pour pour pas
beaucoup d'argent donc voilà là on est
vraiment sur une démarche qui est très
très exceptionnelle donc c'est pour ça
que je voulais vous en parlez vous en
parler maintenant maintenant que ça
vient juste de commencer et j'espère que
ça continuera longtemps que j'aurai pas
fait ça pour rien qui va pas s'arrêter à
quatre vidéos parce que bon ce serait
dommage mais bon parti comme ils sont là
ils ont quand même des bonnes
découvertes ils ont des dents ce qui
veut donc sachant que les humains sont
des mammifères avoir des dents c'est le
plus important
voilà donc ils ont des dents ils ont du
squelette si c'est vraiment à part entre
opus c'est intéressant parce que ça veut
dire qu'ils ont une bande parents trop
pu s'associer avec un squelette
possiblement de part entre opus
or on n'a pas de squelettes de pala
rende pas rentrer opus donc ce serait
super intéressant que ce soit par entre
opus contrairement à ce que j'ai dit à
leurs d'ailleurs je me contredis à la
vitesse du son
voilà donc à suivre moi je pense à
suivre donc aller voir the fall volt le
il ya que 512 abonné je pense qu'ils en
mai avec plus ne serait-ce que par pour
la transparence justement de la démarche
voilà pour le premier article de ce
paléo news on va rester dans la
paléoanthropologie on n'a qu'un article
de paléoanthropologie on va pas faire un
paléo news entier sur la
paléoanthropologie là il n'y a pas que
ça qui s'est passé mais c'est un article
que je trouve très très très intéressant
parce que c'est
c'est un article qui a fait du bruit un
preuve d'une et d'une occupation humaine
au mexique autour de dernier maximum
glaciaire c'est à dire il y a à peu près
trente mille ans donc 33 à 31 mille ans
comme vous pouvez voir ici et ça c'est
intéressant d'avoir des humains à mexico
il ya trente mille ans parce que bas
parce que normalement l'être humain il
enfin pour autant qu'on sache l'être
humain est arrivé il ya quinze mille ans
en amérique en amérique du nord
donc avoir déjà des êtres humains il ya
trente mille ans au mexique
ça pourrait être super intéressant ça
voudrait dire que l'être humain est
arrivé deux fois plus tôt qu'on ne
l'imaginait ça c'est quand même ce
serait quand même super cool ce serait
quand même assez exceptionnel donc
évidemment les plus érudits d'entre vous
savent qu'on a trouvé des possibles
preuves de présence humaine en amérique
du nord
il y à peu près cent mille ans datant
d'il ya à peu près cent mille ans donc
encore plus vieux que 30 mis en jeu lire
70 mille ans plus vieux ses preuves ce
sont juste des traces de découpe sur de
l'os celle qui datent de ya cent mille
ans des traces de découpe sur de l'os
c'est quand même pas évident à
interpréter
et quand on n'a pas la preuve qu'il ya
des êtres humains sur place pour les
faires des traces de découpe sur l'os
enfin interpréter des traces de des
traces de découpe comme étant des traces
de découpe fait par l'être humain sur de
l'os c'est assez c'est assez hasardeuse
parce qu'on sait que par exemple les
alligators et les crocodiles font des
traces sur les os qui peuvent ressembler
à des traces de découpe
donc si vous n'avez pas l'outil avec
c'est pas évident d'interpréter un truc
comme une commune traces de découpe
donc voilà c'est donc c'est pour ça que
c'est assez même si ça a été publié dans
une grande revue et que ça a été pire
review et tout ça il n'y a pas grand
monde qui prend ça pour argent comptant
en tout cas parmi les spécialistes il
n'y a pas grand monde qui prend ça pour
argent comptant tellement que quand on
publie des d'épreuves qui date d'il ya
trente mille en bas elles sont aussi
publiées dans une grande revue comme
nature's ici c'est la revue nature's
donc donc donc bas en tout cas voilà on
enverrait un signal qui commencerait à
sortir qui dirait que l'être humain est
arrivé plus tôt qu'il ya quinze mille
ans alors faut savoir que cette date
plutôt qu'il ya quinze mille ans ça va à
l'encontre des phylogénie moléculaire
qui ont tendance à dire que par
l'horloge moléculaire qui disent que
l'être humain est arrivé en amérique du
nord
il ya entre quinze et vingt mille ans en
gros donc c'est déjà un peu plus vieux
que le registre archéologiques qui lui
ne va que jusque 14 mille ans il me
semble mais bon ça reste assez cohérent
donc une présence humaine ya trente
mille ans ça veut dire qu'il ya une
population humaine qui est arrivé là et
qui a complètement disparu depuis qui a
été remplacée par une autre vague de
migration qui est qui a donné les enfin
les pas les indiens d'amérique mais vous
voyez ce que je veux dire les natifs
américains qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
ce qui veut dire que cette population
génétiquement n'a pas laissé de
descendance
donc bon c'est une grosse hypothèse a
formulé mais quand on a des bonnes
preuves
on peut on peut se le permettre et le
trucks le truc ici c'est que les preuves
c'est juste du lithiques enfin du
lithiques donc c'est des outils de la
pierre taillée et donc ces outils en
face cette pierre taillée je suis
incapable de l'interpréter je suis
incapable de vous en faites
et voilà le truc le truc avec cet
article c'est que je suis pas vraiment
capable de vous donner un avis critique
parce que c'est de l'archéologie de
l'archéologie lithiques j'ai aucune idée
de comment on interprète de
l'archéologie l'éthique donc je ne fais
que vous rapportez ici le ce qui a été
découvert donc on a des outils qui date
de 30 mille ans et qui ont possiblement
été fabriqués par l'être humain
le fait est que ce n'est pas resté
complètement non critique et donc ça il
faut garder ça à l'esprit quand même il
ya eu des critiques il ya des gens qui
disent que on peut avoir des outils
parce que là apparemment enfin la grosse
critique que j'ai vu passer c'est qu'on
est sûr de l'homme moderne
globalement un joli il ya trente mille
ans et homo sapiens donc on est sûr de
l'homme moderne
or ces outils là ils sont pas du tout
symétrie qui sont la taille
semblerait-il n'est pas fine et précise
du tout donc en gros ça ça pourrait très
bien être juste du caillou qui qui
ressemblerait curieusement ça a été
trouvé en grottes et donc les petites
shard qui tomberait du plafond en fait
pourrait ressembler à ça mais bon je
donc voilà il ya quand même des voix qui
se sont élevées parmi les archéologues
pour dire que et peut-être que c'est pas
peut-être que c'est pas du caillou alors
moi avec ma formation de biologie de
biologistes tout ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'ils ont fait des analyses des
analyses adn
donc ils ont fait des analyses l'adn du
sol du sédiment et que dans ses analyses
adn en fait ils ont trouvé des traces de
l'adn de plantes
lorsque vous voyez là du genévrier du
abies je suis pas sur ce que c'est du
pain il ya de l'épicéa donc ils ont
trouvé des plantes ils ont trouvé des
animaux aussi il ya du rongeur il ya du
bison je crois ou est ce que s'est dit
me otis donc ça c'est du rongeur
il ya deux là
il ya du chiroptères donc il ya de la
chauve-souris plus de rongeurs la
marmotte de micropuces je ne sais plus
comment ça se dit dans les gros ouais
voilà il ya de la chèvre voilà la chèvre
caprine et il ya du mouton aux vices il
ya de l'oiseau brefs et il ya même du ya
même du rapace dont il ya du carnivore
ce et donc et c'est là que ça devient
important c'est qu'on arrive même à
retrouver de l'adn de carnivores dans le
tas donc les carnivores c'est plutôt
rare quand même
d'ailleurs il ya aussi de l'ours tiens
voilà je cherchais les groupes les
grosses bestioles ya aussi de l'ours
donc ça c'est les animaux qui sont quand
même relativement rare puisque c'est des
carnivores donc les carnivores sont
beaucoup plus rares que les herbivores
dans les écosystèmes et c'est important
pourquoi parce que au moment de chercher
de l'homme de l'adn d'homo sapiens et
bien c'est ce qu'il ya d'écrit la voilà
we found nord et biden sanchez mendy and
we've been de saint paul ils n'ont
trouvé aucune preuve d' adn humain dans
les échantillons
et alors ça ça ça moi moi ça fait c'est
une alarme mais qui sonne rouge fluo
comme ça parce que comment c'est
possible qu'il y ait eu une occupation
humaine dans un terrain on en a
occupation humaine qui a été
suffisamment intense pour qu'il faut
pour qu'ils aient des outils et les
choses comme ça et qui est sur un
terrain où en plus on trouve des traces
de carnivores donc qui devrait être
normalement plutôt rare mais on trouve
pas les humains en question les humains
dont on a les preuves les preuves
matérielles
on n'en trouve pas les preuves adn ça ça
me semble quand même bizarre
alors après je dis ça mais après je dis
ça je dis qu'on a trouvé de l'adn humain
et c'est plutôt on n'a pas trouvé d'adea
numa pardon et c'est plutôt bizarre mais
au final si on avait trouvé de l'adn
humain le premier truc que je me suis
dit c'est peut-être que c'est juste une
contamination
donc au final qu'ils aient trouvé ou pas
de l'adn humain quoi qu'il en soit
j'aurais été méfiant
donc c'est un peu ça aussi que je me dis
c'est que bon
j'aurais été là j'aurais été assez
méfiant quoi qu'il arrive mais là le
fait qu'ils trouvent pas d'adea numa
alors qu'eux ils ont soit disant des
preuves de d'occupation humaine avec du
lithiques ça ça soulève un sourcil assez
circonspects voilà donc bon donc preuve
de l'existence humaine ya trente mille
ans le truc aussi bas c'est tout
simplement ils ont pas d inhumain et
puis non pas de fossiles humains
d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas de crâne ils
n'ont pas de dents ils ont pas ils ont
aucun fossile ont aucun n'ose donc tout
ce qu'ils ont c'est des trucs qu'on que
certains appellent des outils et que
d'autres archéologues ne veulent pas
appeler des outils bon voilà donc
l'origine humaine en amérique du nord à
l'origine de la migration de l'être
humain en amérique du nord avant quinze
mille ans pour l'instant ça reste je
pense
il faut rester prudent et ça reste un
point d'interrogation
ceci dit c'est déjà mieux que d'avoir
juste trouver des démarques sur des
ossements
c'est déjà une meilleure preuve que des
marques sur les ossements mais ça reste
quand même insuffisant l'on sera on
saura vraiment qu'il y a eu des êtres
humains avant il ya trente mille avant
il ya quinze mille ans quand on trouvera
un crâne de vingt trente quarante mille
ans enfin crâne ou même des dents je le
dire ça suffirait des dents de même des
ossements le dire à vous trouver juste
des ossements de primates en amérique du
nord en fin d'un grand primate même si
vous pouvez pas dire mieux que c'est
juste du primate je n'y a pas il n'y a
jamais eu d'autres primates en amérique
du nord que homo sapiens en tout cas pas
depuis les trente derniers millions
d'années donc juste trouver une phalange
et dire c'est forcément une fois une
phalange de primates
ça suffit pour dire que ces homo sapiens
donc il faudrait vraiment juste un os et
puis cette hausse vous vous faites une
analyse au carbone 14 dessus vous
trouvez qui date de 30 mille ans et
gagner quoi donc je pense que la vraie
bonne preuve qui montrerait que l'être
humain est arrivé en amérique du nord
plus tôt que prévu ce serait vraiment de
l'ossement
on passe aux dinosaures on passe aux
dinosaures bande de petits filous je
sais que c'est pour ça que vous êtes là
donc on passe aux dinosaures et puis je
pense qu'on va passer à ce qui semble
être la fin de la fin du débat sur
aucune lui dans ta vie ce donc le
endgame aux culottes avis endgame la
révélation finale donc au cul nu dans ta
vie pour ceux qui ne se rappelle pas
c'est le petit oiseau enfin c'est un
petit crâne qui avaient été retrouvés
dans l'ombre du miam marc donc dans
l'ombre de birmanie qui datent du
crétacé et qui semblerait qu'ils
semblaient avoir appartenu à au plus
petit oiseau qui est exister au crétacé
donc ce qu'ils avaient qualifié à
l'époque de dinosaures de la taille de
dinosaures de la taille d'un colibri
hamming birds c'est un colibri donc bah
oui bon les oiseaux et temps des
dinosaures un colibri est un dinosaure
de la taille d'un colibri bon mais là
celui là il date du crétacé voilà et il
avait des petites dents surtout il avait
des petites dents et il avait l'air plus
primitif que archéoptéryx en plus parce
qu'ils avaient des dents notamment qui
s'étendait jusque en dessous de l'oeil
en dessous de leurs beats et ça même
archéoptéryx ne l'a pas et ça c'est un
caractère très primitifs pour le coup
donc on avait apparemment un quelque
chose de très dinosauria un oiseau
encore très dinosauriens dans l'aspect
et cet oiseau très dinosauriens dans
l'aspect daté du crétacé avait été
retrouvé en birmanie mais le problème
c'est qu'il ya des gens qui sont
repassés mais vraiment juste derrière
quoi quelques mois après en disant ben
non en fait là vous vous trompez
complètement les dents elles sont pas
tes co2 elles sont pleuraux d'autres
dons qu'elles n'ont pas de racines mais
elles sont implantées sur le l'intérieur
de la mâchoire et ça c'est un truc qu'on
retrouve que chez les squamates donc que
chez les lézards et les serpents
quand les serpents ont plus vraiment les
dents plus rodanthe donc c'est vraiment
les lézards mais bref c'est un truc
qu'on retrouve que chez que chez les
trucs qui sont pas des dinosaures et en
plus il ya même pas de fo santé
orbitaire chez ceux chez ce petit
occupante avis donc il ya même pas de
le crâne n'est pas de type archosaures
or un oiseau c'est un arc aux ordres
normalement vous devriez avoir un crâne
de type archosaures il y avait tout un
tas de petits caractères comme ça qu'ils
montraient qu'en fait c'était plutôt un
squamates et il ya eu alors il ya eu un
débat par publication qui est que je
vais pas vous refaire là il ya
évidemment eu des tirs croisés il ya
l'un des auteurs de l'article sur oculi
dante à vis notamment jim mais o'connor
publié une une phylogénie pour montrer
qu'au cul lui dans ta vie ce sera chez
préférentiellement parmi les oiseaux que
parmi les lézards donc bref il ya eu un
débat par il ya eu un débat par
publication interposés il ya eu aussi un
énorme débat plusieurs débats sur
internet qui on n'est pas tous été très
sympathique d'ailleurs notamment envers
ligne daxing qui est le premier auteur
de l'article qui ont vraiment accusé les
auteurs de malhonnêteté ce parfois de
malhonnêteté d'avoir publié au cul du
dante avis en sachant très bien que
c'était pas un oiseau mais en ayant fait
du forcing pour l'interpréter comme un
oiseau bref voilà et tout ça culminant
avec cette chose d'une seule page et de
quelques lignes seulement donc les
auteurs originaux de la publication
d'aucune aux dents tavis rétracte
l'article ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'en gros l'article est
retiré de la publication ça veut pas
dire que vous pourrez pu le trouver sur
internet mais ça veut dire
qu'officiellement c'est comme si il
n'avait jamais été publié donc c'est
comme si aucune lieu dante avis n'avait
jamais existé
voilà et ça c'est une grande première
pour la paléontologie jeu j'aimerais
bien qu'on insiste là-dessus parce que
c'est vraiment quelque chose en
paléontologie je crois pas qu'on ait
déjà vu des articles rétracter alors
après vous pourrez me corriger dans les
commentaires mais du moins c'est ce que
j'ai cru voir ressortir des débats qui
ont eu lieu sur internet c'est que
vraiment c'est une grande première
en tout cas pour un article qui
décrivait une nouvelle espèce donc voilà
la rétraction c'est pas un acte anodin
généralement en tout cas en
paléontologie
la rétraction neuland on ne l'envisagent
que s'il y avait eu fraude
donc c'est presque enfin le truc avec
ceux justement ce débat houleux autour
de reculer dans ta vie c'est que le fait
de voir l'article rétracter beaucoup de
gens l'interprète comme un aveux de
fraude
voilà l excuse qui est invoquée c'est
que en gros il ya un nouveau ppu
spécimens qui naquit n'est pas encore
publié kenneth qui n'était pas encore
publié à l'époque de recul dans ta de la
publication deux enfin de la rétraction
de l'article qui apparemment
contredirait leur interprétation que
c'était un oiseau sauf que avoir avoir
un spécimen nouveau qui contredit une
interprétation passé c'est tout sauf
comment dire c'est tout sauf nouveau en
paléontologie je veux dire c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose qui s'est pas
quelque chose qui se passe jamais en
paléontologie je veux dire il ya qu'à
prendre basilosaurus par exemple
basilosaurus c'est une baleine qui au
départ a été interprété comme un reptile
comme un grand serpent
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il s'appelle
basilosaurus alors que généralement la
terminaison pour les mammifères c'est
therion zaurus c'est la thermie nation
pour les la terminaison pour les lézards
donc enfin pour les reptiles de manière
générale donc c'est pas là je veux dire
c'est pas le premier
c'est pas la première fois qu'un truc a
été mal interprétés et a ensuite été
réinterprétés quand on a trouvé du
nouveau matériel
donc c'est plutôt bizarre comme réaction
et ça a déclenché énormément de débat
est le plus important de ces débats ça a
été du coup qu'est ce qu'on fait de
reculer dans ta vis maintenant d'une on
occulte dans ta vie est ce qu'au cul nu
dans ta vie ce existe toujours
ça c'est une bonne question ça parce que
maintenant que l'article officiellement
n'existe plus entre grosses guillemets
n'existe plus dans qu'est ce qu'on fait
d'eux qu'est-ce qu'on fait du non au
cumul dans ta vie alors il y en a
beaucoup
moi y compris qu'ils pensaient à la base
que vu que l'article avait été
rétractées il y avait plus de
descriptions puisque le
la description était dans l'article donc
le nom au culot dante avis étaient
attachés à une description et que cette
description du coup n'existait plus de
fait vu qu'il n'ya plus de description
aucune entente avis devient un domaine
nous sommes donc un nom nu parce qu'il
n'a plus de descriptions attaché dessus
donc ça rendait opulente avis invalides
mais il ya un dubois donc du muséum
d'histoire naturelle de paris qui a
publié un article qui met les choses à
plat et qui dit que non concluantes avis
en fait ça marche toujours
donc il ya même un petit résumé en
français si vous êtes intéressés pour le
lire au cully nantes avis il existe
toujours
après ils invoquent ce que ce qui semble
être plus de une pirouette on va dire
dans les règles de la nomenclature que
plutôt une règle bien établie on va dire
il assez bon voila si c'est la décision
du comité de nomenclature de conserver
au cul nu dans ta vie ce quand bien même
il n'ya plus de descriptions attaché
tant mieux je veux dire c'est voilà tant
qu'il ya une décision qui a été prise ma
foi c'est bien le problème c'est qu'on
est resté pendant une période 1-1
instants de flottement où s cocu lui
dans ta vie c'est existant encore ou pas
bonne question
et par dessus ça il ya encore un autre
article qui est sorti alors qui est pas
encore sorti parce que lorsque vous
voyez c'est encore la version manuscrite
mais qui a été acceptée pour publication
donc c'est juste qu'il n'a pas encore
été mise en page là encore un autre
article qui est sorti qui décrit
justement le nouveau spécimen en
question donc le nouveau spécimen que
que linda xing et ses collègues invoqué
dans leur rétraction en fait il a été
publié juste après et ce nouveau
spécimen c'est effectivement un spécimen
un peu plus complet que je vais vous
montrer maintenant toutes les images
sont à la fin voilà donc c'est un
nouveau spécimen dans l'ombre
vous voyez qu'il a un crâne mais qu'il a
aussi un peu de postes crânien donc il a
un peu de squelette est donc ce
squelette à des écailles ce qui a décrit
ici dorsale scale donc ce squelette à
des écailles donc c'est définitivement
pas un oiseau
ce qui finit d'enterrer et puis même là
sur le crâne ici vous voyez il ya encore
des écailles sur la bouche
donc ce spécimen est définitivement pas
un reptile donc définitivement pas un
oiseau mais bien un reptile donc ça ça
finirait de planter le clou dans le
cercueil docu lui dans ta vie en au
moins en tant qu oiseaux pas en tant que
espèces puisque comme on l'a dit
l'espèce est toujours valide du coup
mais en tant qu oiseaux en tout cas
c'est fini
après je trouve ça un peu bizarre ce
nouveau spécimen parce que la voilà le
crâne du nouveau spécimen voilà le crâne
du spécimen de lolo type donc du
spécimen original docu le dante avis il
n'y a pas besoin d'être un grand
spécialiste pour voir qu'ils sont pas
pareil je veux dire quand bien même on
considère l'écrasement l'écrasement de
ce spécimen par rapport à celui là quand
bien même on corrige pour l'écrasement
je le dire le la les pariétaux sont
quand même vachement plus bombée que sur
celui là ici vous voyez là il ya une
crête sur le nez qui est super longue et
qui est super visible qui est même
visible sur cette image là quand on le
regarde du dessus vous voyez il ya une
crête sur le nez qui est très très
longue et très visible qui ne l'est pas
là
là vous voyez que la crête elle est
presque aussi haute que le crâne alors
que là la craie enfin si on considère ça
comme étant une crête elle est toute
petite
voyez que le maxillaire ici il est
vachement plus épais alors même que
normalement le spécimen est écrasé dans
son ventre allemand donc normalement le
maxillaire devrait pas être aussi épais
donc il ya plein de différence il ya une
différence majeure aussi c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de ya pas de foramen pinéale sur
ce spécimen alors que là la première
enfin pas la première description la
seconde description du crâne nos
culottes avis parlé d' un foramen
pinéale à cet endroit là d'ailleurs on
voit toujours il est ici donc ils sont
pas si similaires que ça en fait c'est
alors c'est un peu étrange qu'ils les
attribuer à au cul du dante avis parce
qu'ils se ressemblent pas vraiment après
ils ont certes un caractère qui sont
très très particulier il ya alors cédé
caractère qui sont aussi très
spécialisés donc au final c'est un peu
c'est pas hyper c'est pas hyper utile de
les décrire la mais voilà il ya quelques
caractères qui sont très spécialisés et
qu'on retrouve apparemment que chez ces
deux spécimens là et chez aucun autre
les arts mais est-ce que ça qu'on pense
vraiment pour les différences convoi
entre les deux non pas que je doute
qu'il soit peut-être proche parent mais
de là à les appeler tous les deux
occupantes avis et à les attribuer tous
les deux à la même espèce
ça semble un peu ça semble un peu
prématuré donc bon je pense enfin j'ai
dit fan parti pour reculer dans ta vie
ce la sortie de ce nouvel article me
suggère qu'on me crie que en fait non je
pense qu'on est encore loin d'une fin de
partie pour occupante avis je pense
qu'on en entendra encore parler
documente avis parce que ce spécimen là
ça m'étonnerait qu'il reste au cul nu
dans avis très longtemps si ça se trouve
d'ailleurs avant d'être publié cet
article là sera corrigée et puis
finalement ils l'appelleront plus aucune
dans ta vie c'est là du coup ça voudra
dire que l'on revoie laporta
à des interprétations différentes du
spécimen originale dont bref et cet
article d'ailleurs il est accompagné par
cette très belle reconstruction de docu
lui dans ta vie sous on voit d'ailleurs
très bien la crête donc ils
reconnaissent complètement l'existence
de cette crête la compression dorsaux
ventrale et à peine corrigé donc ça veut
dire que pour eux ça veut dire que pour
eux ce qu'on voit là c'est pas si loin
de la vérité
donc bon donc à part la très très grande
taille de l'orbité
ces deux spécimens à première vue ils se
ressemblent pas tant que ça donc bon on
va voir on va voir ce que le futur nous
réserve je suis pas spécialiste des
squames hâte après voile comme comme ils
disent les deux spécimens ont quand même
des caractères 7 certain caractère hyper
spécialisés qu'on ne retrouve que chez
ces deux spécimens donc je ne doute pas
d'après leur description que les deux là
soient proches parents donc ce spécimen
là le nouveau spécimen indique bel et
bien que ce spécimen ci est un squamates
est un lézard sayah je pense que
maintenant c'est fini il ya plus trop à
discuter par contre je suis pas
complètement convaincu que ce nouveau
spécimen devraient être appelés au cul
dans ta vie à mon avis on est face à un
autre genre au moins une autre espèce
quoi
bref donc la whey d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
dans le texte
je n'ai jamais me rende compte à
l'instant mais dans le texte il
n'appelle au cul dans ta vie ce qu'en
gare et donc qui est le nom original
comme comme gras et pardon c'est pas
évident a prononcé vous m'accorderez il
l'appelle au cul nu dans ta vie ce
congrès alors que dans la figure dans
cette figure là il l'appelle au cul dans
ta vie ce sp donc dans la figure il
exprime beaucoup plus de de prudence que
dans le corps du texte la la la limite
sera un peu plus d'accord pour la plus
opulente avis s p au moins au moins dire
que ces différences de morphologie du
crâne en font deux espèces différentes
peut-être du même genre mais deux
espèces différentes bon bref
mais là on est sur un débat qui est
purement taxonomique donc ça devient un
peu ça devient un peu ennuyeux donc
voilà aucune vente à vis c'est un lézard
et ça m'étonnerait que ça m'étonnerait
qu'on entend qu'on n'entende pas encore
parlé double négative
donc on passe maintenant du côté des
arts need is tiens quand bien même on
n'était plus vraiment en train de
considérer oculi d'antalis comme étant
réellement un théropodes mais on passe
du côté ornithischiens de l'arbre des
dinosaures avec une nouvelle philosophie
ni des dinosaures qui est enfin des
dinosaures c'est rapide c'est à dire des
cératopsidés et des pâquis ses fans aux
orres proposé par des chercheurs belges
et français principalement donc paul
émile dieudonné je crois qu'il est belge
pascal godefroy est définitivement belge
et thierry tortosa qui est français à la
limite s'ils sont dans l'école en terre
ils pourront nous dire pour nous
confirmer et kruse ados caballero par
contre j'ai aucune idée de sa
nationalité
donc je ne vais pas m'avancer mais bref
donc des chercheurs francophones
voilà principalement francophones qui
nous propose une nouvelle phylogénie des
dinosaures théropodes dans laquelle en
fait ils nous disent que donc vous avez
ici
en gros les laisser rate obtient avec
vous voyez par exemple si tu as coteaux
russie s'y li hao ceratops
et en fait c'est ceyrat obtient on sait
depuis longtemps qu'ils sont qu ils sont
rattachés aux pâquis céphalo zoo rien
donc ici que vous pouvez voir ici vous
n'avez pas qui c'est fallows aux russes
notamment qui est juste la steg au
sérail juste à côté bref les pâquis ces
phases on n'ose rien et en fait ce
qu'ils proposent eux et basses et que
tout un tas de petits dinosaures dont on
ne savait pas trop quoi faire et qui
datent du jurassique et bien en fait ils
appartiennent à la branche des pâquis
c'est fallows au rider et ça c'est une
hypothèse qui est très très très très
provocante qui est très très très très
très peu accepté d'ailleurs j'ai pu en
discuter avec des collègues
il n'y a pas grand monde qui est très
d'accord avec ça il met notamment voyez
des trucs sud africain comme et héros
dont deux aux russes et abricots aux
russes des trucs sud africain du tout
début du jurassique
ils en font des des pâquis ses fans au
zoo rider et mes collègues sont pas du
tout d'accord avec ça parce qu'en fait
pour eux c'est que ce qui skie branche
en fait ces hétéros d'autorité aux
pâquis ses fans au zoo rider c'est
essentiellement des caractère primitif
notamment la rétention la rétention de
dents prêts maxillaire donc apparemment
il semblerait que dans la façon dont ils
ont codé la présence de dents des dents
prêts maxillaires en fait sa force
la présence de dents prêts maxillaire à
être une si napo morphy au lieu d'être
une plaisions morphy donc si vous y
connaissez un peu en cladistique ça vous
parle si vous n'y connaissez rien sachez
juste que c'est contestées voilà c'est
très contestée et ça a pas fait ça n'a
pas fait du tout du tout du tout
l'unanimité
il ya une autre raison pour laquelle ça
va pas fait l'unanimité c'est que si
vous regardez cet arbre en fait
phylogénétique vous voyez que si on vire
ici là les étés rondeau torride et donc
tout ce petit monde en fait et qu'on
garde que les pâquis ses falaises au
rider et bien on constate qu'en fait les
ceyrat obtient et les pâquis céphale
autorités apparaissent globalement en
même temps donc à la fin du jurassique
du mois ceclad la voilà peut-être pas
les pâquis ses fans aux rides et les
plus d arrivée
on connaît le mieux mais au moins cela
quoi ils apparaissent à peu près en même
temps au jurassique donc ça c'est si on
considère que c'est pas qui sait pas
l'odeur idée c'est encore pire ils
apparaissent qu'à la fin du crétacé
bref quand quand vous déjà quand vouliez
enfin quand vous lier ces ceyrat obtient
aux pâquis ses fans aux orchidées
vous avez une petite ligne et fantômes
de quelques millions d'années pour
pouvoir les reliés les uns aux autres
voilà une lignée fantôme c'est un une
branche de l'arbre sur lequel il ya
aucun fossile est là le problème c'est
qu'en reliant les pâquis ses fans aux
rides et tout en bas du jurassique avec
les et les hétéros dottori des balles à
vous avez une lignée fantômes qui qui
s'étend tout le long du jurassique qui
est ça représente quand même alors si
vous regardez là vous avez entre 150 et
200 millions d'années donc ça représente
une lignée fantôme de près de 50
millions d'années donc 50 millions
d'années pendant lequel normalement il y
avait des pâquis ses falaises au rider
et on les trouve pas et en plus 150
millions d'années pendant laquelle il y
aurait des pâquis céphale aux au rider
qui ressembleraient à des hétéros notons
hors du coup et y en aurait eu partout
parce que les pas qui c'est fait le zoo
reid et en plus on les trouve pas
partout on les trouve que dans
l'hémisphère nord et encore pas partout
dans l'hémisphère nord et là d'un seul
coup on a des fossiles sud africains qui
viennent s'ajouter aux mixes donc c
c'est une hypothèse qui est très
contestée du point de vue temporel est
très contestée du point de vue
géographique aussi donc ça donc je pense
pas qu'elle fera qu'elle fera de vieux
zoo cette hypothèse je pense pas qu'elle
fera date
mais elle est assez intéressant c'est
intéressant de voir qu'il ya encore que
des gens qui quand même sont capables de
remettre en question d
comme comme on le disait dans une vidéo
précédente les certaines théories qui
sont des vieux arbres et il faut les
secouer pour voir s'ils tiennent encore
debout et je pense que voilà depuis je
crois que c'est serré nos qui avait
proposé les de lier les pâquis ses fans
aux orres aux autres hisser au serrat
obtient et du coup ça donc c'est depuis
2007 je crois donc ça fait déjà une
quinzaine plus qu'un en 13 ans c'est ça
fait déjà treize ans que ça a été
proposé donc bon c'est bien de secouer
un petit arbre qui a 13 ans faux le
secouer et voir s'il tient encore et
puis ben c'est un peu comme c'est alors
c'est pas un peu comme les ornithos
élida c'est les ornithos élida c'est un
paradigme vieux de 150 ans qui est
secouée mais voilà faut secouer faut
secouer et puis il faut voir si ça tient
et puis bah si ça tient et bien tant
mieux et si ça tient pas
heureusement qu'on s'en est rendu compte
à temps c'est surtout ça c'est pas tant
pis s'il faut s'en rendre compte à temps
et à temps c'est n'importe quand en
science ça peut être n'importe quand en
qu'on s'en rend compte
voilà autre grosse hypothèse qui a été
secouée encore pendant les vacances
c'est celle c'est celle de l'origine des
arts need is qu'un ajustement comme je
disais on est du côté des arts need is
tient toujours donc toujours du côté des
dinosaures herbivores où cette fois eh
bien il ya des gens qui ont proposé
alors pour le coup je ne les connais pas
du tout donc je n'avais même pas essayé
de commenter sur qui sont ces personnes
mais en tout cas c'est publié dans l'est
dans les proceedings of the royal
society donc c'est grosse revue grosse
grosse crédibilité
c'est des gens j'ai jamais réussi à
publier la temps typiquement c'est pas
faute d'avoir essayé
non ils veulent pas ils veulent pas de
moi si vous n'avez pas un bon gros
bagage derrière vous globalement ils
veulent pas de doute donc donc bon ne
pas vouloir me publier ça veut pas c'est
pas une preuve de crédibilité mais bon
si je suis là pour témoigner que ils
prennent pas n'importe quoi non plus
quoi je veux dire il ya des fois je leur
ai envoyé du lourd et même du lourd ils
n'en veulent pas ils veulent que ce soit
à béton carré bref
dont bref les procédés of the royal
society c'est pas des guignols et donc
là on a les ornithischiens ici en verre
et en fait les ses auteurs proposent de
alors on va peut-être partir du départ
les ornithischiens donc ils apparaissent
au jurassique
or les dinosaures ils apparaissent dès
le début du jurassique avec justement
hétéro d'auto russes par exemple et les
autorise donc vous les voyez là les
autorise ces hétéros d'autoriser parmi
les plus anciens là vous avez même et au
cur sorte qu'ils incluent parmi les
ornithischiens qui est aussi plus vieux
donc ils apparaissent au début du
jurassique voir voir voir voir
apparemment fin que le passé n'ont même
pas non non non le début jurassique on
confirme début jurassique ils
apparaissent au début du jurassique le
problème c'est que quel que soit le
groupe frère d or ni tisca donc que vous
considérez que c'est les théropodes ou
que vous considériez que ce sont les
sauts risque tient les souris ce cas et
les théropodes eux ils apparaissent dès
le trias donc encore une fois on a un
problème de ligne et fantôme vous voyez
là c'est longues branches ici que vous
voyez là c'est longues branches qui
n'ont aucun fossile bas ça c'est tous
des lignes et des fantômes et ça fout un
peu le bordel donc
donc on est face à un problème de ligne
et fantômes
on est face à
un problème de soi soit il y avait des
artistes yann le trias et on n'a
toujours pas les fossiles soit il ya
certains fossiles du trias qu'on connaît
déjà mais quand on n'a pas interprété
comme étant désormis titien et bien eu
ce qu'il propose avec à travers de leur
nouvelle analyse c'est qu'en fait il ya
un groupe de trucs qu'on ne considérait
même pas comme des dinosaures on les
considérait comme des dinosaures au mof
on appelle ça les si les eaux rider donc
on est considéré même pas comme des
dinosaures est bien pour eux non
seulement ce sont des dinosaures mais en
plus ce sont les ancêtres des arts need
is tient et l'hypothèse est encore une
fois assez provocante parce que les cils
et les si les eaux les silésiens les 6,2
au rider sont des carnivores
donc ce serait les ancêtres carnivores d
or ni this kia avant qu'il ne devienne
herbivore parce que de toute façon les
archosaures son primitivement carnivores
donc on sait que la condition carnivore
est forcément ancestrales pour les arts
need is tiens donc les cils les si les
eaux rien seraient les ancêtres
carnivores désormais 10 kg à 1 et c'est
pour ça qu'on a une grande lignée
fantôme c'est parce que en fait ben en
fait on s'est trompés depuis le début
les on avait on a toujours eu ces
fossiles en face des yeux c'est juste
qu'on les avait pas identifié comme
étant désormais 10 kg 1 et on aurait des
animaux comme et héros dont deux aux
russes qui ferait un peu le pont
morphologiques en fait entre les six les
orient et les ornithischiens parce que
et héros dont deux aux russes comme son
nom l'indiqué à des dents et héros donc
ce qui veut dire qu'il a non seulement
des dents qui sont adaptés pour la
nourriture herbivores mais il a aussi
des grandes canines et des incisives
pointu qui pointent plutôt vers d'un
régime qui est carnivore dans ce cas là
donc il a des molaires d'herbivores mais
il a des canines des incisives de
carnivores donc c'est intéressant comme
hypothèse
et puis encore une fois c'est assez
c'est assez provocant ça secoue des
vieux arbres
encore une fois on secoue des vieux
arbres et puis on va voir donc
je ne suis pas suffisamment spécialiste
de la question pour vous dire pour vous
donner à un niveau de crédibilité à ça
puis encore une fois ce qu'il va donner
le niveau de crédibilité à ce genre
d'hypothèse comme pour les ornithos
élida c'est le facteur temps quoi c'est
combien de fois est ce que des gens vont
reproduire cette fille le une phylogénie
comme ça est tombé sur ce même résultat
résultat d'ailleurs si vous regardez
bien qu'il ne soutient pas la mono fil
idées ornithos élida donc là pour eux et
eux ne retrouve pas les ornithos élida
par contre il retrouve les nra zo rider
pas loin des fins à la base des
saurischiens au lieu de les retrouver
avec les théropodes comme la plupart des
phylogénie le font donc encore une fois
bon c'est un jeu de cartes et on rebat
les cartes et on voit faut voir c'est
faut rebattre les cartes et voir si ça
ressort et plus à ressort et plus on
peut il donner de la crédibilité donc
pour l'instant c'est des hypothèses qui
sont là qui existe et on s'est plutôt
intéressant c'est plutôt intéressant en
fait de voir qu'il ya des gens qui se
posent des questions sans arrêt et qui
veulent qui veulent tester ces
hypothèses voilà c'est pas des dogmes
contrairement à ce que certains disent
c'est pas des dogmes un paradigme c'est
pas un dogme c'est une hypothèse qui est
fortement qui est fortement établie mais
qui est toujours questionnable
on repasse du côté de théropodes de la
force avec avec une étude de microraptor
en fait d'un des plus d'un des fossiles
de microraptor les plus connus c'est
celui là voilà c'est genre celui que
tout le monde connaît et en fait il ya
des chercheurs pareil que je ne connais
pas dévoyé des là pour le coup ainsi
jean mais o'connor badging mais o'connor
d'ailleurs elle travaille sur les ailes
travail aussi elle a aussi travaillé sur
occultes dans ta vie ce cas on l'a vu
son nom tout à l'heure avec aux curieux
dans ta vie ghinzu ces machines choo je
crois que ça se prononce comme ça c'est
celui qui avait publié microraptor à la
base si je me rappelle bien mais bref
donc il ya quand même des gens connus
dedans et donc dans cette dans cet
article en fait cédé ces gens là se sont
rendus compte que sur ce fossile qui est
connu depuis très longtemps 2
microraptor ça des fossiles les plus
connus une microraptor et bien toutes
les plumes ne sont pas au même niveau
voyez ici c'est coloré en lacets bien
coloré et où toutes les plumes sont pas
au même niveau il ya des plumes qui sont
encore en train de pousser et sait
alterner c'est à dire que vous avez une
plume ou deux qui sont enfin vous avez
une plume qui est fortement développé
une plume qui ne l'est pas une plume qui
est fortement développé une plume qui ne
l'est pas une plume qui a fortement
développé et c est ça s'éteint c'est ce
qu'on appelle d'une mule séquentiel et
cette mue séquentiel et
un caractère qu'on retrouve chez les
oiseaux voyez une plume développer une
plume en train de pousser une plume
développer une plume en train de pousser
et c'est cette mue séquentielle est une
condition nécessaire au vol puisqu'il
faut quand même avoir quelques plumes
développer quand on est quand on est à
un animal volant il faut quand même
avoir une partie de ses plumes
fonctionnel pour pouvoir voler donc
c'est ce qu'on voit chez cet oiseau là
vous voyez que la bon pour le coup là
celui là il est vraiment fortement déplu
mais celui là il est très très très très
très des plumes et lui il a perdu toutes
ses plumes en même temps donc ça c'est
des les animaux pour lesquels le laisser
les oiseaux pour lesquels le vol n'est
pas une condition nécessaire à la survie
mais pour les oiseaux chez qui le vol
est une condition nécessaire à la survie
vous voyez que les plumes sont très
développés et qu'il ya une remplacement
séquentielle de ses plumes donc c'est
non seulement on a chez microraptor donc
un terreau pod non aviens un
remplacement qui est typique de celui
des oiseaux mais en plus la condition
est quasiment identique à ce qu'on voit
chez les oiseaux modernes volant ce qui
tendrait à confirmer que microraptor ce
avait volé une nouvelle qui n'a pas pu
vous échapper je crois que c'est
vraiment la plus grosse nouvelle que qui
est souvent sorti récemment à propos de
la paléontologie en tout cas cet été
c'est la découverte de tissus cancéreux
sur un fossile d'un ceratops ya donc un
centre auto russe
j'avais jeu j'ai sur mon tweet
enfin j'ai gelé partager sur twitter et
sur facebook j'ai appelé ça un
tricératops
j'avais pas vu j'avais pas vu la petite
reconstruction là c'est un centre aux
orres bref c'est un ceyrat obtient donc
c'est sur ce centre aux russes on a le
tissu ici qui a été mis en jaune qui est
du tissu cancéreux et les sections à
travers enfin les sections fine qui ont
été faits à travers cette hausse indique
qu' il s'agit d'un cancer et que ce
cancer c'est un cancer
qui est malin donc c'est pas c'est pas
une gentil tumeur qui fait pas de mal
parce que ça existe les gentils tumeur
qui font qu'ils font pas de mal on en a
retrouvé plein donc c'est ce qui
explique que dans le premier paragraphe
on a retrouvé plein de d'ossements de
dinosaures avec des gentils tumeur
bénigne mais là c'est une tumeur maligne
c'est une tumeur qui a probablement
causé la mort de l'animal pour le coup
et c'est la première fois en fait qu'on
retrouve une tumeur maligne chez un chez
un dinosaure et du coup ça c'est un
instant qui fait date puisque puisque
puisque ben puisque ça veut dire que les
cancers
ça veut dire que les cancers ça existe
depuis très longtemps ça on le savait
mais les cancers malin on ne savait pas
mais maintenant on sait voilà maintenant
c'est sachant que ce type de cancer
existe chez l'humain et maintenant on
sait qu'il existe aussi chez le
dinosaure ça veut dire que l'ancêtre
commun des amniotes avait déjà le cancer
donc on ça veut dire qu'on peut au moins
dater l'origine du cancer de 400
millions d'années 400 voire même 420
millions d'années donc c'est plutôt
intéressant
alors il ya des gens qui ont qui se sont
jetés sur la conclusion de savoir il ya
des gens qui n'aiment pas les
végétariens voilà où les vegan et qui du
coup se sont jetés sur la conclusion du
fait que bah voilà centraux aux russes
c'est un herbivore et il a quand même le
cancer et ce cancer l'a tué donc ça veut
dire qu'être herbivore ça sert à rien ça
protège pas du cancer
certes mais c'est pas nouveau c'est pas
exactement nouveau le fait que d'être
herbivore vous protège pas du cancer je
veux dire les vaches on cancer
donc voilà donc je sais pas pourquoi je
sais pas pourquoi il ya des gens qui
vont immédiatement qui se sont
immédiatement jetés là dessus d'autant
que la biologie d'un centre aux heurts à
mon avis doit être suffisamment
différente de celle d'un d'un être
humain pour qu'on puisse dire que qu'on
voit pas le rapport
je veux dire on peut on peut largement
contre argumenter que l'on voit pas le
rapport quoi
bref pourquoi pas pourquoi pas la news
suivante qui n'est pas du tout une news
puisqu'elle a été publié en 2018
c'est un article du blog tétrapodes
zoologie mais qui est ressorti en fait
récemment parce que darren neish la re
tweeté récemment en fait et j'ai trouvé
intéressant de de leur partager ici à
travers les paléo news c'est en fait le
fait que les dinosaures à bec de canard
n'avait absolument pas un bec de canard
est quand le sait grâce à un fossile de
préservation de tissus mous d'un sur un
sur un nuran aux orres dans un et de
mentors pardon sur un an et de manteaux
aux russes voilà donc voici le crâne
d'edmonton aux russes donc c'est ainsi
un crâne dont on pourrait croire qu'il a
un bec de canard puisque vous voyez que
la bouche est complètement aplati donc
si on rajoute juste une petite un petit
bec par dessus ça on peut bien
s'imaginer que la forme du baix suivait
la forme de l'os et bien il y à un
fossile donc est la cm 23 500 2 ce
fossile préserve la rend photek c'est à
dire le bec le bec de kératine
donc c'est une préservation de tissus
mous assez exceptionnel on est bien
d'accord que c'est pas un truc qui
arrive il ya qu un seul spécimen je veux
dire c'est pas un truc qui arrive tout
le temps
et bien ce que c'est être en faute et
que vous voyez à la patte du tout la
forme d'un bec de canard n'épouse pas en
fait la forme du crâne
ce qui fait que toutes les
représentations de dinosaures à bec de
canard que vous avez pu voir de votre
vie partout sans probablement
complètement fausse ce qui est pas
subtilement suggéré par ce dessin en
fait voilà toute votre vie vous avez cru
que les dinosaures avec deux canards
ressembler à ça ben non pas du tout il
ressemble à ça voilà votre enfance
ruiner en quelques phrases par darren
niche qui qui vous rappellent
l'existence de ce fossile qui vous l'a
rappelle parce qu'apparemment il a été
décrite dès 1970 donc c'est pas un
fossile particulièrement nouveau en fête
je crois qu'il cite la référence voilà
maurice 1970 voilà c'est là que ça avait
été décrit et puis bah de est néanmoins
depuis les années 70 les gens continuent
à représenter les dinosaures à bec de
canard avec un bec de canard alors que
ça ressemble pas du tout du tout du tout
à bec de canard et enfin dernières news
sur les dinosaures après on passe à
autre chose parce que quand même y'a pas
que les dinosaures dans la vie c'est
c'est une nouvelle étape dans la fin on
franchit une nouvelle étape dans notre
compréhension de l'évolution de landau
thermie c'est-à-dire delà de l'évolution
du sang chaud chez les dinosaures
puisque les dinosaures sont originaires
de reptiles très bazoquain dame iott
très bas zoo qui était à sang froid et
aujourd'hui les oiseaux sont à sang
chaud ça veut dire que quelque part dans
la phylogénie des dinosaures ou des
archosaures du mois le sang chaud
apparu un métabolisme à sang chaud est
apparu on sait que ça c'est produit
maintenant la question c'est quand et
chez qui est est ce que les dinosaures
étaient à sang chaud est ce que tous les
dinosaures étaient à son show la réponse
de ce que cet article nous fournit et
que oui
alors comment ils sont arrivés à cette
conclusion ils ont observé la
composition chimique des coquilles
d'oeuf de plusieurs dinosaures donc des
carnivores comme trop donc des
théropodes des ornithischiens comme le
maïs aura et puis de d d d d d que je me
trompe pas il ya aussi des titanosaures
m'aider titanosaures qu'ils n'ont pas
observé eux mêmes mais qu'ils ont eue
par la littérature donc d'aider
titanosaures qui sont des sauropodes qui
ont été observés par d'autres personnes
et donc ils ont observé ce etc
alors ce qu'on appelle les isotopes de
l'oxygène et si je me trompe pas c'était
des isotopes de l'oxygène bandés c'est
la composition chimique en général parce
que là je vois qu'il ya du fer et du
manganèse apparemment donc il a observé
la composition chimique en général
n'étant pas moi même un géochimiste je
vais pas non plus commencer à
m'aventurer trop profondément dans cet
article je les lui mais bon on ne
comprend pas tout non plus mais en gros
si vous regardez là vous avez la
température vous avez ici la masse
corporelle et donc la température ici
bas en dessous de 30 degrés c'est grosso
bonne au sang-froid au dessus de 30
degrés c'est grosso modo sang chaud avec
évidemment une petite
il aurait peut-être dû mettre une petite
zone grise ici un bon mais pourquoi pas
donc ils ont comparé la composition
chimique de leurs hôtes de leur coquille
d'un oeuf de dinosaure coquille d'un
oeuf de dinosaure qui grossissent qui
grandissent vraiment profondément à
l'intérieur du corps d'une femelle donc
normalement les eaux enfin le loeuff et
formé à température corporelle
donc normalement reflète sa géochimie
devrait refléter la température du corps
parce qu'en fonction de la température
du corps ce n'est pas les mêmes éléments
chimiques qui vont former la coquille du
moins les ratios isotopique vont pas
être les mêmes
est ce qu'ils trouvaient bien c'est
qu'apparemment chez les sauropodes
cessange au cheylard chez eux en it is
qu'un qu'ils ont regardé donc maya saura
il y en a qu'un c'est sans chausser
chambre sans même très très chaud
apparemment 45° pas loin de 45 degrés
donc ces mêmes oiseaux ca vient ce
niveau là comme température corporelle
et chez les théropodes comme ils ont un
peu plus d'échantillons
ben là ils ont un peu plus de
variabilité voire même jusqu'à du sang
froid alors comment ils savent que à
partir de là c'est sang froid parce
qu'ils ont aussi fait la géochimie
isotopique sur des moules et des
gastéropodes qui ont été trouvés en même
temps donc des moules et des escargots
quoi en gros dés des moules d'eau douce
et des escargots qui ont été retrouvés
en même temps au même endroit que c'est
que ces fossiles
donc c'est pour être sûr en fait que la
signature isotopique n'est pas dû à un
processus de fossilisation en fait donc
tu étais obligé était on peut pas juste
analyse et les autres dinosaures et voir
si le ratio chimiques et 100 chevaux
sang froid non il faut aussi comparer à
des fossiles qui ont été trouvées au
même endroit et dont on est sûr qu'ils
sont à sang froid est donc là pour le
coup les gastéropodes et les moules
c'est lassant froid il n'y a pas de
souci et ils ont été retrouvés au même
endroit donc on regarde leurs coquilles
le ratio géochimiques de leur coquille
et ça ça nous indique ce que c'est que
le sang froid et là apparemment on
trouve que chez les théropodes il ya
aussi des espèces enfin il ya aussi des
échantillons à sang froid
sachant que leur terreau potes c'est
essentiellement trop donc si je ne
m'abuse donc donc un résultat qui alors
eux ils l'interprètent comme étant en
cessant chaubon un résultat mitigé au
final pourrait-on dire
et puis et puis et puis comme je comme
jeu comme je les dis je suis pas
spécialiste de la géochimie donc si si
il préfère interpréter ça comme
métabolisme à son show bain
bon je soulève un sourcil en regardant
ça en regardant ces deux échantillons là
qui sont définitivement du côté sang
froid de la force et je me dis on va
attendre plus de preuves
sachant que bon toute façon les preuves
s'accumulent et s'accumulent pour dire
que les dinosaures étaient en tout cas
pas à sang froid probablement pas à sang
froid
sachant que la géochimie isotopique là
dans ce cas là ça vous dit seulement la
température du corps ça veut pas
forcément dire qu'ils étaient capables
de réguler cette température du corps
d'ailleurs j'en profite par lasser endo
terminé pas aux mairies terminant doté
remis c'est la capacité de générer de la
chaleur l'eau mais au terme hisser la
capacité à garder sa chaleur constante
et on peut garder sa chaleur constante
quand on vit dans les eaux tropicales
par exemple comme les tortues luth ou
bien quand on vit bas en régions
tropicales en général puisque les
régions tropicales la température est
constante de toute façon ou bien quand
on est gigantesque
comme les sauropodes par exemple les
sauropodes ils sont tellement gros que
le simple fait de bouger un muscle
réchauffe tellement leur corps ben que
de toute façon ils sont nommés au terme
alors quand bien même qu'ils sont pas
forcément qu'ils sont pas forcément en
d'autres termes qui sont pas capables de
générer physiologiquement cette
température c'est juste le fait de
bouger leurs muscles d'ailleurs j'ai dit
une bêtise les tortues luth sont plutôt
considérés comme des gigues en termes
comme les sauropodes elles sont
tellement grosse que le simple fait de
bouger leurs nageoires génère
suffisamment de chaleur pour qu'elle
garde la température de leur corps à peu
près constante mais les espèces
tropicales donc à un corail par exemple
qui vit ceinture de corail
il est haut mais au terme parce que il
reste à la même température tout le
temps normal il vit dans les eaux
tropicales
alors quand bien même que les coraux ne
sont pas capables de générer leur propre
chaleur et puis il ya des mammifères qui
génèrent leur propre chaleur mais qui ne
sont pas haut mais au terme comme par
exemple les les ours les ours ils
génèrent leur propre chaleur mais en
hiver leur chaleur diminue donc donc
leur chaleur leur température interne
chute parce qu'ils y berne
donc voilà faut donc là pour le coup ce
qu il quantifie c'est l'eau mais au
terme y plus que landau termine donc
c'est là c'est un seul aspect de ce
qu'on appelle le sang chaud
pas les deux aspects qui sont la
capacité de régler sa température et la
capacité de générer sa température mais
c'est un pas de plus on va pas on va pas
évidemment critiquer juste pour le
plaisir de critiquer c'est un pas de
plus qui nous indique c'est un indice de
plus dans une faisceau de preuves
voilà ce qu'on demande c'est un faisceau
de preuves le plus complet et ça c'est
un pas de plus mais c'est pas l'article
qui va vous dire c'est bon c'est fini le
débat est réglé non c'est juste une
preuve de plus un petit peu
d'invertébrés maintenant pour vous
signaler la sortie d'un nouvel article
sur les lits mule donc les limites qui
appartiennent aux grands groupes d'exil
chaussures articles qui est sorti le 9
juillet 2020 dans la revue frontiers of
times et qui est très intéressant c'est
un article en fait de revue donc c'est
vraiment ça ça passe en revue tous les
tout ce qui a été publié récemment au
moins sur l'évolution des lits mulet de
leurs ancêtres xiph aux yeux et auxilia
très intéressant dans cet article les
basses et que ça nous illustre
parfaitement bien que la famille d'eddy
mule est très très loin d'être le
fossile vivant qu'on est très loin
d'avoir cette image de refléter cette
image de fossiles vivants qu'on donne
souvent ou limule voilà vous avez les
limites moderne mais vous pouvez voir
que les limes il va ça n'a pas toujours
ressembler à delhi mules et ça c'est
quand même super super intéressant donc
c'est un article dont bon voilà qui nous
apprend rien de nouveau sur l'évolution
des dix mule
quant au moins si vous connaissiez déjà
l'évolution des lits mulet si vous ne la
connaissez pas et bien je vous invite à
aller le voir parce que c'est un article
très intéressant qui nous rappelle par
exemple découverte de ce spécimen de
lits muldi l'ordovicien si je ne me
trompe pas du silurien voilà c'est écrit
là ni mule du silurien qui donc a des
pattes comme les limites moderne mais
qu'il ya aussi des branchies
contrairement aux limites moderne et qui
démontre très très bien que non les
limites ne sont pas des fossiles vivants
et ont et qui résume donc la diversité
la diversité morphologique des lits mule
comme je le disais je vous montrais ici
les lits mule il y en a eu de toutes les
formes il y en a probablement eu de
toutes les couleurs même si la couleur
n'est pas pour réserver et donc là ça
vous rappelle vraiment tout le registre
fossile des xix faux sur lies mule
inclus donc ça c'est quand même super
intéressant et puis c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on parle de deux d'invertébrés
dans paléo news
donc voilà c'est si vous voulez tout
savoir des lits mules et que vous voulez
savoir clouer le bec à ceux qui disent
que c'est des fossiles vivants
c'est l'article que vous voulez lire
vous le voulez vous voulez lire cet
article
et puis on termine en dehors de la
paléontologie on va sortir un petit peu
des sentiers battus de la paléontologie
juste pour parler un petit peu de
mammifères pour parler de mes préférés
les afro terres à des afro terre
elle-même et un frottèrent probablement
préféré que sont les 5 j les saint jean
qui est le mot massaï pour parler de
rahat rompent qui ne sont pas des rats
mais qui par contre on une trompe
attendez que je vous trouve une photo
voilà donc les samedis voici la nouvelle
enfin la nouvelle non c'est une vieille
espèces en fait une espèce qu'on avait
découverte il ya très longtemps de qu'on
appelle la leur à trompe de somalie donc
elephant illustré voili qui était connue
il ya très longtemps et les compensées
éteinte et qui est restée éteinte dans
du moins dans nos registres pendant je
crois trente ans quelque chose comme ça
et puis ça y est ils viennent de la
retrouver viennent de la retrouver et
ils ont même réussi à en extraire de
l'adn en regardez moi cette bouille déjà
avant qu'on parle de l'adn regard des
marchés de bouille
elle est trop belle et rebelle cette
salle j c'est trop beau les samedis il
faut il en faut plus y en faut plus j'ai
eu de la chance j'ai eu la chance d'en
voir une sauvage une fois bon j'en ai vu
un zoo évidemment mais j'ai eu la chance
d'en voir une sauvage une fois c'est
trop mignon
j'ai pas pu prendre de photo mais
c'était trop mignon voire des mois ça
regardez moi ça cette bouille
c'est trop beau
donc ils ont fait des analyses adn
dessus alors évidemment il re
caractérise l'espèce donc
morphologiquement parlant donc une
petite différence dans terre des petites
différences dans le pelage dans la forme
du nez mais surtout ils font une analyse
génétique et alors cette analyse
génétique avait très très très
intéressant très intéressante parce que
en fait elle s'appelle normalement
éléphants tullus ray voili que voici que
voilà
mais en fait voici le clad des éléphants
qu luce est en fait rêver wali ne tombe
pas du tout dans le classe dans le clad
des éléphants tullus du tout donc en
fait on pensait avoir perdu faut voir
l'application du point de vue de la
conservation de l'espèce c'est à dire
qu'on pensait avoir perdu une espèce
d'éléphants tullus parmi tant d'autres
il y en a une dizaine je crois d'espèces
d'éléphants tullus donc on pensait en
avoir perdu une parmi tant d'autres et
en fait non si elephant illustré voilier
avait disparu c'est pas une espèce qu'on
aurait disparu c'est un genre entier
parce que du coup ils en font ce que
vous voyez que là vous avez le genre
petro de romulus vous avez le genre
macro cds vous avez le genre éléphants
tu lui c'est là vous voyez que ça forme
un clad totalement séparée de tous ces
gens un peu plus proche de petro drôme
us qui vient d'afrique centrale si je ne
m'abuse donc est et d'afrique du nord il
ya petro d'euros un an
il y avait trop de remous cia petros
halte à tort pardon donc là vous avez
petro d'euros musset petros halte à tort
donc petro drôme us vient d'afrique
centrale petros halte à tort c'est
l'ailé c'était autrefois aussi pensé que
c'était un éléphant tullus et en fait
non et ça c'est là si vous habitez en
afrique du nord et au maghreb
c'est la salle j que vous pouvez voir là
bas c'est le raa trompe que vous pouvez
voir au maghreb il ya qu une seule
espèce au maghreb et ses pétro salt à
tort rosetti et donc là vous voyez que
si ces deux là sont des genres séparer
alors elephant illustré voile y ait
forcément un nouveau gens aussi et de
fait ils l'ont appelé que je ne me
trompe pas ça doit être dit dans le
dans le résumé le voilà c'est galets
jsqu'à ray voirie donc voici un nouveau
genre d'éléphants tulle issu d'une
espèce qu'on croyait éteinte qu'on
croyait qu'elles n'existaient plus mais
qu'elle n'existe en fait et ça c'est
super cool et comme je disais c'est un
des implications sur la conservation ça
veut dire que quand bien même il ya des
espèces qu'on croyait connaître et bien
quand on réalise réanalyse l'adn bah en
fait on les connaissait pas et si ray
voiliers avaient disparu et bien on
aurait perdu
vous voyez un deux trois quatre cinq on
aurait perdu un cinquième de la
diversité des macros c'est lydie né de
la famille des macros sedin et donc
c'est quand même pas rien
un cinquième de la diversité des macros
celi dîner qui aurait disparu
complètement au lieu de juste une espèce
de l'éléphant tullus quoi donc c'est
important pour la conservation et je
trouve ça trop cool qu'on retrouve
encore des nouvelles espèces de d'afro
terre aujourd'hui c'est trop la classe
est le dernier article c'est plus un fun
fact qu'un article mais c'est quand même
parue dans les proceedings encore une
fois le crous revue donc et c'est des
gens qui ont mis des draps sur des sur
des chevaux voilà c'est des gens qui ont
mis des draps sur les chevaux alors ils
ont mis un drap noir ils ont mis un drap
gris des draps rayé rayé verticale rayon
horizontal et ils ont même mis à damier
et ils ont voient ils ont regardé en
fait là combien de mouches donc ici
c'est des temps en l'occurrence ils ont
regardé combien de mouches leur
atterrissez dessus des temps l'art
atterrissez dessus donc voilà les noirs
il y en a beaucoup les grilles il y en a
un peu moins et alors les rayures
horizontales verticales et les damiers
il y en a pas du tout et du coup ça a
des implications évidemment sur
l'évolution des zèbres et en quoi le en
quoi les rayures sont une adaptation
pour repousser
enfin qui sert à repousser les
essentiellement des les mouches donc
vous avez peut-être entendu la théorie
que les rayures servait à se camoufler
des lions apparemment non c'est plutôt
une adaptation contre les pestes donc
les mouches les temps et aussi les
mouches tsé-tsé il y avait eu des
expériences similaires avec les mouches
tsé-tsé qui avait été fait
est ce que ça nous montre aussi c'est
que ce qui repousse les insectes
apparemment c'est pas le temps le fait
d'avoir des rayures verticales puisque
les rayures horizontales et le damier on
vous voyait le à peu près le même effet
voire même un meilleur effet d'ailleurs
donc ce qui repousse ce n'est pas
tellement le fait d'avoir des rayures
verticales c'est le fait d'avoir une
alternance en fait de deux noirs et de
blancs qui ont l'air de qui doivent
casser la silhouette où on sait pas en
fait ce que ça montre en gros c'est que
l'on croyait qu'on savait pourquoi les
zèbres été rayée que c'était pour
repousser les mouches tsé-tsé mais qu'en
fait on sait pas vraiment ce que ça nous
montre c'est qu'en fait on sait pas
vraiment parce qu'on pensait que
c'étaient les rayures verticales qui
avait un effet de casser la silhouette
de l'animal et que les mouches avaient
du mal
coût a repéré l'animal en fait non c'est
pas spécialement attaché au fait qu'ils
ont d ailleurs verticale les rayures
horizontales et les damiers ça marche
aussi donc on sait pas exactement
comment ça se fait que les mouches ne
n'arrive pas atterrir parce que c'est ça
après qu'ils montrent en fait c'est que
les mouches n'arrive pas atterrir sur
les chevaux rayé donc les zèbres les
ailes et simulation de zèbres j'ai envie
de dire il arrive pas atterrir dessus
donc c'est un peu bizarre mais en tout
cas c'est donc même si on sait pas
comment ni pourquoi
la conclusion de tout ça c'est que si
vous voulez échapper au temps cet été et
bien il faut porter des marinières voilà
c'était paléo news je vous remercie de
l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner pour ne rien manquer l'ancien et
à très bientôt
[Musique]